governor steve sisler paying his
respects on this memorial day he spoke
during a ceremony at the southern nevada
veterans memorial cemetery that's right
joe muller was there he shows us how
this day takes on a different meaning
for service members and their families
families of those who lost a loved one
serving our country attended today's
ceremony we spoke to one woman about
what this day means to her 18 marines
were sitting in a truck
when a suicide bomber came out from
behind the bridge
hit their truck my son was sitting on
this side
helena lucas is remembering her son john
lucas he was an extremely good boy he
died at the young age of 19 in 2004.
when he died
i was completely devastated
her son paid the ultimate sacrifice she
came to the southern nevada veterans
memorial cemetery to remember him many
others came to thank john for his
sacrifice and to thank helena today we
honor and pay tribute to those who
sacrificed everything governor steve
sisselok shared a message at the
ceremony i want to recognize the family
and friends of our fallen service
members the cemetery was full of
american flags and many families
remembering those they lost after the
ceremony of flyover took place by the
boulder city veterans pilots group we
need to
remember not just
those who pass but the families sean
schmidt is from the vfw post in
centennial hills he says the post was
named after john lucas and now his
family is a part of theirs by naming the
post john lucas
we get to
just share that with them and he's he's
lives forever on through us while
memorial day is a day many enjoy off
with family i just really hope they will
take a moment
and they will think of that
here are these brave people who died for
our country lucas hopes people remember
why the day is here in the first place
and remember those like her son we just
have to say thank you thank you for your
service i enjoy this freedom that we
have joe muller live local now